[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and today I'm excited to be
talking about one piece again in the
comments to our attack on Titan and my
hero academia videos on every Titan
explained and every quirk explained
we received a surprisingly large amount
of requests to make an every devil fruit
in one piece explained video and after
the crazy amount of support we've
received on our 10 ways for kids changed
one piece video we decided to create
more one piece content for you guys now
while we really loved the idea of
quickly explaining all of the devil
fruits and one piece for you guys there
are way too many devil fruits to fit
into one video so we decided to break
them up by type we are starting with
logia and if this video gets over 1000
likes and it should be able to since
their last ones are over 3000 very
thankful for that then we will be happy
to make videos about the paramecia and
zone devil fruits as well as I'm sure
you already know devil fruit is a
magical type of fruit in the world of
one piece that if eaten by someone
allows that creature to use incredible
superhuman abilities the specific nature
of these abilities depends on the type
of devil fruit and logia devil fruits in
particular allow their users to
manipulate a natural element produce an
unlimited amount of that particular
natural element and to turn into that
element these natural elements can
include fire ice smoke sand electricity
and more and while devil fruits can be
insanely powerful they do also have
their weaknesses and logia type devil
fruits are no exceptions as we will see
as the video goes on certain devil
fruits are superior to others and the
power of hockey which is similar to the
concept of life force and fighting
spirit allows those who have mastered it
to inflict damage on the true body of a
loggia user despite the fact that loki
users are generally able to avoid other
types of attacks due to their ability to
become
tangible if you are new to this channel
don't forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell for more one piece
content as expected with a video like
this one there will be some spoilers so
proceed with extreme caution and without
further ado let's do this Mokomoko no
mean the first logia food to ever appear
in one piece Mokomoko enemy grants its
user control over the element of smoke
the user can create and manipulate smoke
and he can turn himself into smoke which
allows him to absorb incoming attacks
and also to fly through the air the user
of this double fruit is smoker and he is
known for surrounding his opponents with
smoke and then making the smoke more
dense in order to grab and attack them
smoker can also use his powers for more
practical purposes such as powering the
engines on his motorcycle the element of
fire appears to be on equal footing with
Mokomoko Nomi and when clashing against
the fire based mana mana Nomi the two
powers seem to cancel each other out
nevertheless like other logia users
smoker can still be hurt by the use of
hockey meta meta know me this level
through grants its user control over the
element of fire which means that the
user can create and manipulate fire and
turn himself into fire this devil fruit
was first used by Ace and later by Sabo
as is expected of fire as an element the
user of a can generate extremely
powerful offensive attacks and the
ability to become fire gives the user
the additional ability to avoid
conventional physical attacks while in
that state meta meta Nomi has been shown
to be an even match for other logia
Devil food powers such as ice and smoke
but the magu magu no me devil fruit was
shown to be stronger as its magma based
power is superior to conventional fire
magu magu no me and speaking of magma
below me this is a battle fruit that
allows its user to create manipulate and
turn himself into magma the extremely
hot fluid that comes all the way from
the Earth's crust used by fleet admiral
sac uzuki this devil fruit like other
logia devil fruits
renders its user invulnerable to
conventional physical attacks while in
magma form and its user is able to
launch powerful offensive attacks move
quickly by blasting off like a volcano
in a particular direction and melt earth
and stone beneath him in order to move
around underground
as mentioned earlier magu magu told me
was shown to be more powerful than the
fire based powers of aces met a better
know me and it also has the power to
boil seawater and instantly melt entire
icebergs in terms of outright power this
is one of the strongest logia type devil
fruits especially considering the fact
that it has no known element specific
weakness hiki no me and while we're on
the topic of ice hehehe no me grants its
user control over the element of ice the
user can generate manipulate and turn
into ice and while in their ice form the
user is able to move quickly for long
distances the user of this devil fruit
is clues on formerly known as Admiral al
ki ji he he no meet has demonstrated the
power to freeze entire tsunamis and
Kuzon is also able to use it to freeze
portions of the sea in order to lock
himself and others to cross it hehe no
me is more powerful than Yuki Yuki Nomi
which allows its user to control the
element of snow due to the fact that ice
is cooler than snow however hehe know me
is one of the few logia type fruits that
is vulnerable to some forms of physical
attack because ice is a solid element so
physical attacks will not simply pass
through it nevertheless
cusan has the ability to regenerate the
ice after it has been damaged and he is
able to form holes in his body in order
to evade physical damage Yuki Yuki Nomi
next is the previously mentioned Yuki
Yuki Nomi which grants its user control
over the element of snow and as usual it
enables the user to generate manipulate
and become snow used by Monette before
returning to circulation upon her death
Yuki you can know me can generate giant
snow storms or make the user invisible
inside an already existing stones
and it also has the ability to regulate
the density of snow the smoke can go
from being nearly intangible thereby
allowing the user to avoid physical
attacks and flow through the air to
being solid enough to create powerful
barriers or walls in addition if she
gets close enough to her opponents
Monette can immobilize them by draining
the heat from their bodies Yuki Yuki
Nomi is vulnerable against heat and
Monette as a user was shown to let her
mental state affect her power for
instance in Chapter 687 she lost control
of her transformations as a result of
extreme fear soon Asuna Nomi suna soon
Indomie grants control over the element
of sand enabling its user crocodile to
generate manipulate and become sand an
extremely versatile devil fruit soon as
soon anomie allows the user to create
sand storms absorb liquids which allows
him to minimize his own weakness to
liquid and sense natural phenomena
around him including underground rivers
and quicksand as a result of his mastery
of the devil foods power crocodile can
avoid sneak attacks by transforming it
the sand reflexively which is something
that less experienced logia devil
through users are unable to do and his
powers are stronger if he is in close
proximity to desert areas in addition
crocodile has the ability to consume the
fluids of anything he comes into contact
with allowing him to dehydrate people
animals and plants to the point of
withering and he can even make earth and
stone crumble into dust steel and metal
objects are the only materials that are
unaffected by his power numa numa no me
sorry guys I couldn't help myself all
right now back to business Numa Numa no
meat grants is user the ability to
generate manipulate and become a mud
like substance that we can refer to as a
swamp used by I'm just gonna say caribou
this devil fruit has the ability to
generate a bottomless swamp it that no
one can escape from this pit can be used
to store an unlimited number of objects
and living beings that are able to
survive in water for example mermaids
can actually live inside the pit by
turning into his swamp form caribou can
elongate certain parts of his body and
like most other logia devil fruits numa
numa no meat is intangible and is
therefore able to avoid damage from
physical attacks however unlike most
other loggia users caribou must absorb
everything rather than allowed to simply
pass through him the one glaring
weakness of this devil food is that if
the user can be trapped into entering a
space in his swamp form that his
physical body cannot fit into the user
will be trapped there as demonstrated
when frankie captures caribou by
trapping him inside a barrel in chapter
606 go to go to know me aka pika-pika no
chew yes
that was bad but so worth it it enables
its user to control the element of
lightning including the ability to
generate electricity manipulate
electricity and become electricity
sometimes referred to as a nearly
invincible devil fruit go to go to non
meat is used by NL and now is capable of
generating up to 200 million volts of
electricity and is able to electrocute
someone who tries to touch him when in
lightning form the user can travel at
the speed of lightning and in case his
heart never stops beating he can use the
electricity to shock it back to life
essentially bringing himself back from
the dead the user can sense electrical
sound waves around him which together
with the Nels mantra ability allows him
to have a clearer sense of everything
that is going on around him this is
obviously an incredibly powerful devil
fruit but it is important to note
that because Luffy has a rubber body and
rubber is an insulator and so it doesn't
conduct electricity Luffy has a unique
advantage against the user of Berto
gonna know me he definitely hit the
jackpot with this matchup
yummy yummy know me yummy I mean know me
grants is huge readability controlled
darkness and it is said to be rare even
among logia type devil fruits in fact
yum yummy know me is so unique that many
people feel that it is not a true logia
and that it might actually be a
paramecia but for now most sources still
classified as a Lohia type devil fruit
during his battle with ace the devil
fruits current user Blackbeard claims
that yami yami no means power is the
most evil
this devil fruit has the ability to
create a black substance that exudes
from the users body this substance has
its own gravitational pull and its sucks
opponents in and everything else around
it like a black hole which is an
incredibly effective power to have in
battling this devil fruit is so powerful
that Blackbeard was able to consume a
whole entire city and on top of this
insane absorption ability he also has
the power to render the abilities of all
other devil crews useless if he touches
their users and maintains direct contact
with them one important weakness of Yami
Yami know me is that because it absorbs
everything the attacks launched against
the user will not pass through him and
according to Blackbeard himself his body
actually absorbs much more pain than a
normal person's I personally really like
this notion of a type of equivalent
exchange that they have in one piece
where even if you are really strong you
usually have a weakness to make up for
it it makes the world of one piece a lot
more interesting pika-pika know me
pika-pika know me grant is user control
over light enabling him to generate
manipulate and become light used by
Borsellino a.k.a admiral kazuto this
devil fruit allows its user to travel at
the speed of light which makes him the
fastest being in the world and
also allows him to use offensive
techniques including extremely powerful
light beam attacks his immense speed
makes his physical attacks exponentially
more powerful and he is also able to use
blinding flashes of light similar to
Crellin solar flare in dragon ball
nevertheless kizlet who cannot attain
light speed instantly and there's a
short window of time in which a quick
opponent can attack his little and stop
him from going into light speed mode
furthermore despite its immense power
the effects of pika-pika no me can still
be countered with hockey as demonstrated
during quezada's fight with silvers
Rayleigh gasps ooh gasps oh no me gasps
ooh gasps oh no me
grants its user control over the element
of gas allowing them to generate
manipulate and become gas by becoming
the gaseous substance the user of this
devil fruit can float through the air
and gain access to the narrowest of
spaces used by Caesar cloud gasps ooh
gasps tsunami also has toxic and
explosive properties making for a
powerful offensive weapon moreover the
user of this devil fruit has the ability
to control other gaseous substances
around him that are not directly
connected to him
so for example he can suck out the
oxygen from a particular area and
suffocate everyone else there and he can
even absorb other gases in order to make
himself more powerful undoubtedly an
incredibly powerful devil fruit when it
comes to offensive capability gospel
gospel only is theoretically weak
against fire but Caesar cloud is able to
minimize this vulnerability by removing
oxygen from his immediate area and of
course fire needs oxygen to burn now
that was the cannon logia devil foods
the ones that appear directly in the
manga now we are going to look at the
non cannon or anime only logia powers
tora tora no me in the second one-piece
movie called clockwork island adventure
we are introduced to a loggia type devil
fruit called Toro Toro Nomi which grants
its user the ability to generate
manipulate and become a jelly esque
liquid as with most logia devil fruits
Toro Toro Normie allows its user to
physical attacks by allowing objects
have passed through it and honey Queen
the user of the devil food also has the
ability to use liquid blast attacks and
squirm through narrow spaces one
peculiarity about tora tora Nomi is that
honey queen does not transform her
clothes when she goes into liquid form
so the clothes are simply left behind
this devil fruit also has a few
weaknesses the user does not appear to
have physical strength when in their
liquid form and just like with Newman
Newman told me if the user of total
total Nomi is tricked into entering a
space in a liquid form that their
physical body cannot fit into the user
will be trapped there Nami succeeds in
trapping honey Queen inside a glass jar
I mean I'm in no me in the fourth movie
called the adventure of that end we are
introduced to another logia type devil
fruit called amiami Nomi which allows us
user to generate manipulate and become a
syrupy element that appears to be liquid
candy in his candy form the user Gaspard
is able to absorb opponents and their
attacks rendering them immobile guests
parred can make his body liquid and
sticky which allows him to absorb and
trap opponents and he can also make his
body solid and hard allowing him to turn
parts of his body into sharp offensive
weapons due to the elastic properties of
syrup the user of omnium enemy can
elongate and stretch parts of his body
but this devil fruit sweetness is flower
if he comes into contact with flower the
user will stop being intangible and
becomes vulnerable to physical attacks
pasa pasa know me and finally pasa pasa
know me is a devil fruit that we are
introduced to in the 2002 one-piece
video game called big secret treasure of
the seven phantom islands this devil
through grants its user control over the
element of paper enabling him to
generate manipulate and become paper and
I'd assume delivers some excruciating ly
painful paper cuts
there is some debate about whether this
non-canon devil
can be considered a logue at all but we
will include it on this list simply
because lots of people have classified
it as logia in the past the user of this
devil fruit is the primary antagonist of
the video game Simon and he appears to
be able to take the form of any type of
paper with the power of pasa pasa no
meat Simon can evade attacks and also
launch explosive paper projectiles at
his opponents needless to say however
this paper based devil fruit is weak
against fire and that's it for this
video guys
thanks so much for watching especially
if you watch all the way to the end if
you enjoyed this video smash that like
button and don't forget to subscribe let
me know what your favorite logia fruit
is in the comment section below and like
I said if we can get 1000 likes will do
either zone or paramecia next and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]